hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
III stage I'm your host Mike McCarty
here with UK editor tomorrow sane and we
are joined by a head of Xbox so Spencer
head of Xbox how's it going so good I
was lovely three it's a fun time of year
fans are are they in yet I don't know I
think they're just now coming in about
an hour from down there yeah energy was
was in the room you can feel it body
temperature the temperature in the room
was also going up over to the public is
here like 15,000 public tickets yeah you
know I'm on the the board that runs the
ESA that runs III and we've had a lot of
feedback from both publishers and
developers that they want to see more
consumers in the show because you know
III kind of was born out of us building
games retailers coming in see what games
they like so they could preorder copies
for the fall get their orders ready but
now so much of gaming is about like this
direct to talking to the gamers selling
to gamers so it's having consumers here
I think is a good thing yeah
and it's a big show for you in the
Microsoft team unveiling what used to be
project Scorpio we now know it's the
Xbox 1x what's it like for it to be
finally out there we know the price you
know what's coming out we know what it
is yeah it's probably one of our biggest
t threes ever for us when you just think
about the importance of it
we had our briefing on Sunday new day
for us in terms of our press briefing
showed 42 games 22 with console
exclusivity on Xbox one and then
unveiled Xbox one X I'll try not to slip
in and call it Scorpio over and over and
it was great like that energy in the
room was great we've got the world's
most powerful console for a value
customer who's looking for an everyday
console play game for their family we've
got s that the world zones powerful with
X playing true 4k had a great showing of
the games on stage to show the power you
you weren't you two weren't in the arena
right so we built this 50 foot 4k screen
in the arena which was incredible did
the 4k streams out to people so they
could see the quality of the games a lot
of fun yeah I do want to talk about the
the press conference itself because you
know you have as consoles like you
yourself coming from a development
background yet we can you extensively
interview after interview about you know
how consoles are making their way more
to the PC kind of a hardware upgrade
cycle and now you have Xbox
is you have Xbox one X and then you have
PlayStation for the PlayStation 4 slim
the pro when you look at the Xbox one X
at the price it is $4.99 who are you
mainly targeting I know you're trying to
bring in people are you trying to
upgrade people from the s are you trying
to bring in people from Sony maybe that
particular like stick the PlayStation
who is the crowd that is coming in
because I mean seems like a fair price
point but it still might be a little bit
hard sell like to sell 4k at $4.99 yeah
and that's why the family of consoles is
important because like I said there's a
lot of food here in the US right now the
S is 249 and for a lot of people they're
coming in hey I want to play fifa I want
to play Madden I want a console for the
family and that's going to be a great
value for them I mean we all know
because we're in this industry there's
also a customer that's looking for the
most premium experience one of the
things I've talked about a little bit
here and I didn't really think about
this before I got down here but I
remember two years ago I was taught he
was two years I was talking about the
elite controller do you remember our X Y
and I $150 number there was a lot of
discussion around hey well how who's
gonna spend $150 on a controller and I
knew we had built $150 controller
I felt it I play with it all the time
and we put that in the market in the
holiday and we couldn't build enough
like they were all gone but that's not
for everybody we sell and Xbox one s
Xbox one X is the same thing there's a
premium customer wants very best true 4k
gaming you know that consoles
on a league on its own right there
nothing else that's close to it in terms
of specification and there's a core set
of people out there who are going to
want that very best experience either on
their 4k television
we've also through super sampling
enabled great fidelity on a 1080p
television but most of the consoles we
sell next year will be s and that's fine
I want to give people Choice I'm really
thrilled with the reaction from the
developer community to the power that we
were able to put in the Xbox one X and
even the development console and how
people are getting their games up in a
native 4k resolution so quickly and give
to give gamers choice give consumers
choice and they come in build the best
development platform we can for
developers and and it was a good show
and I'm can't wait to launch November
7th yeah learning I do want to get in
specifics in a little bit about the
abstract itself and the games but to
talk about that I mean we're coming up
to e3 I think the
what was Project Scorpio the x.now was
probably the biggest thing everybody's
watching out for right um
but you only devoted like a small
portion of your press conference to that
before just Breitling through 42 games
was that kind of a reaction to the last
couple a 3s were people people had maybe
been criticizing uh not enough focus on
the games whereas you know I think the
common refrain is that Sony that's all
they did and I think they went for that
this year but this year you just went
through it was 42 games right yeah what
is that was that a reaction last year
was that just like a new direction that
you want to take even though you had
like the most powerful console coming
out it's a great question there were a
few things that came together one it
made the decision a little while back
that we weren't going to stay within the
90 minutes that we normally were at so
we had a little more time we actually
start planning for e3 back in December
funny enough and we start to get okay
what games we want to talk about both
from our first party as well as
third-party partners how are things
looking and what are the themes and so
we picked on some themes that just
honestly took us a little longer to go
through in the presentation we had a lot
of great content and you think we wanted
to show 4k games we were able to show
forts off the beginning motorsport 7
which I thought look fantastic at 60
frames per second Metro is a game I've
loved for a long time and now I don't
know that everybody knew what Metro was
when we showed it on screen but I
remembered from the 360 we've got
obviously the games on Xbox one and I
just looked at the visual fidelity of
that and I want to put that on stage
closing with anthem another day 4k but
then I also thought about you're seeing
games like pub gee you know player
unknown battleground and able to get
that on our stage and have Brennan up
there talking about bringing it to
console working with us first on on Xbox
to have that game come so we had this
community section and then there was
this international thing I wanted to
bring into our show because it's I think
it is I've received the feedback we want
more games for more places on the planet
so to have Dragon Ball code bein black
desert from Korea like a lot of great
games last night would not be yeah and
and Metro absolutely from the Ukraine
it's so it was really the sections of
content I wanted to talk about smaller
games bigger games games from everybody
and it just took more time I didn't
actually plan for 42 games it was it's
kind of what we landed on and tried to
trim it back and there was nothing I
to pull out of the show one of the one
of the big things that people are
picking up on is you know use announce a
new console and generally the kind of
plan is to announce a big first party
game that kind of attaches to that
console and shows the power of that
console and you did have a lot of games
but there was kind of a dearth of first
party games you have Forza and so people
are obviously looking for a Halo or
Gears or something like that but you
didn't quite have that kind of big
Microsoft kind of IP to be like this is
our you know flagship product or title
for this console can you speak to a bit
why you decided to focus on third
parties because at the moment it's like
a lot of people will be looking at that
and seeing a lot of third party games
and then weighing up whether they want
to buy an additional console for games
that kind of exists in other places PC
or ps4 or yeah I think it's it's
absolutely a fair question
the I'll focus on both first party and
third party on the third party side I'm
confident that the best versions of all
the third party games are going to be on
Scorpio like the horsepower inside of
that console just makes that kind of
almost impossible for a developer not to
end up there because again the console
is just so much more powerful than
anything else whether it's the pro the
slam or the S it is and it's its price
differently so it kind of should be but
on the third-party side I wanted to make
sure that people knew that the
third-party games are going to run best
on this console so I wanted to have the
third-party games like Assassin's in our
show like anthem at the end which I
thought looked incredible and Patrick
coming out and talking about anthem
running on the X on our stage I thought
that was a great opportunity on the
first party side crackdown sea of
thieves state of decay minecraft in 4k
which doesn't always pick up the same
kind of buzz here at e3 but I kind of
tease some people when they kind of push
on this minecraft bigger than any game
you're going to a stage it's great you
know yeah and and I thought the work
that they did in 4k well maybe not -
exactly - the e3 audience though the
reaction in the arena was actually nice
to hear having minecraft in 4k with the
new graphics literally might be more
impactful than anything else that
happens for Honor's right that is just
such a huge opportunity having Ori show
up there and be able to announce a new
Ori one of my favorites from this
generation on the Halo and Gears thing
specifically I was proud that we were
able to show 42
games and not show Halo and Gears
because people know we're working on
Halo and Gears right those are important
franchises for us Gears was getting in
the update to 4k and we were showing it
in the arena that kind of a special
section where people go to see Xbox 1x
content in play on 343 I was just down
there two weeks ago I can say they're
doing some great work exercising what
Xbox 1x can do both on some of their
past games as well as looking forward
we'll probably have more to talk about
that soon but I think that both teams
are actively working but the fact that
we could land 42 games on our stage 22
with console exclusivity and not a
failing gears about with a strength so
one of the things that you said is that
you want to parties third play games to
be best on Xbox one Xbox one X oh yeah
how do you kind of balance that with
games that have deals for example let's
look at destiny to announce that it's
going to run at 30 frames per second on
Xbox one X 1/2 and that is a game that
you can according to the technical
specifications be run on Xbox one X at
60 frames per second but then obviously
they're in a situation where they can't
have it run better on the Xbox and in on
the ps4 because they have a deal with
Sony like are you going around and
encouraging people to kind of make that
jump and you know really tick but how do
you balance that when you've got more
platform games that will have some
allegiance to another platform and can't
look better on one than the other I'm
gonna struggle do not get myself in
trouble on this one
you know you mentioned earlier might
developer background like I started
Microsoft as a programmer I've been
around game development it's the launch
of the original Xbox I'll just say I'll
say it if I don't know anything about
other development deals so you mentioned
some things around clauses and stuff
that I only think about but if anybody
was to do a deal to hold back technical
innovation on a video game anywhere else
that doesn't feel good for the industry
to me okay that's I've said I'm not one
who's a fan of going out and doing deals
so that a certain skin isn't playable on
a different platform or a different
strike and people come and say hey X you
guys did that first
dooty way back in the day I wasn't in
this position when that happened That's
not me
ducking responsibility for it but I
didn't make that call but the deals that
we do now and you saw our third-party
relationships on stage with shadow of
war with assassins you're not going to
hear them say anything about hey a
certain character that's not playable
and I never go into a situation where I
said you can't do something that's
possible on another platform in order to
benefit I don't I don't think that's I
haven't seen those deals if that started
to happen in the industry I don't think
that's a great thing I don't know that
it has happened you know use like I do
but I know right now the technical
capability on Xbox one address is beyond
like I look at like pro slim s is kind
of in one category and then you've got a
box as you said that can natively do a
lot more
whether developers choose to use the
horsepower for frame rate resolution or
just techniques within the frame is up
to them like I'm not going to dictate
I've heard this okay you should force
all games to be 60 or something I've
never thought forcing the creative
process is a great way to get great game
I guess like it's clear that the Xbox
one X is the more powerful console of it
but the worry amongst the community now
is we're in a situation where you have
this exponentially more powerful
hardware than the compare but they're
both kind of bottlenecking each other so
there's there's the situation where we
will we ever get to see what that
console can do in its entirety just I
think that's something that people are
kind of afraid of the multiplayer for
multi-platform games and in that case it
leaves it to you guys to do show what it
can do with first party games which we
will yeah I'll say I've seen I was
listening to my friend Jesse from arc
did an interview this week where he just
talked about the capability of Xbox 1x
and what was possible on the pro and I
think the ps4 bro isn't a nice console I
think it's a console that's just at a
different price point and different
capability than in projects with an Xbox
one X so I don't that's a scorpion but I
so I don't kind of link them together I
agree with you that it's our job as an
industry to showcase what hardware can
do whether it's in the PC space whether
it's in the console space I'm really
happy with the reaction we talked about
over 30 games from third parties that
are going to get updates for Xbox one X
we have to show Final Fantasy Resident
Evil Ghost Recon Rock
leagues of teams doing some really
interesting things I think from load
times from resolution to stable frame
rates just because the increased CPU GPU
memory bandwidth capability the box I'm
very confident that the games are going
to show best on Xbox 1x cool yeah as a
follow-up question to that and like
again with your background as a
developer when you see consoles going
the way of PCs with just so many
different options to take from does that
make it harder for developers at all to
account for the Xbox one axis your multi
platform like you can tell the coalition
and you can tell 343 make your game
based on these specs and they look great
I'm sure on the X but when you have
multi platforms like we just mentioned
like does that like muddle the process
of like what do we need to meet for this
console what do you need to meet for
discounts like going to the future do
you think there's a way to standardize
all that or do you think it'll always
kind of be a case-by-case basis and two
things I'd say there we pick the spec of
Xbox one X looking at what was going on
in the PC space around six teraflops in
the memory bandwidth and frankly now
that we give me nine gigabytes to game
developers and said okay if you're
already building a PC game which most of
the third parties do and you have a 4k
capability in your PC game we want to
make sure it's very easy to bring that
over to Xbox one X and see your game
running in a native 4k very quickly and
all the reports we've talked about this
publicly that we've been seeing that's
been happening very quickly and then the
team looks at the overhead Cape that
they have left on the box and they're
cranking things up to the different
texture resolution and other things that
they want to go do I mean you mentioned
it though the number of developers that
only target one platform on the planet
is almost zero even if your first party
Sony for starting Microsoft you're
focused on two different specs if you're
a third party you've got PC specs from
dual Titan sli in some PC you know all
the way through maybe even an integrated
GPU in a certain laptop so I think the
development process for third parties is
already capable from a pipeline
standpoint and rendering standpoint of
creating assets and rendering assets at
multiple specs we picked xbox one X
looking at what we were learning because
we happen to have Windows as well so we
kind of can see what's going on with
DirectX and said okay this is going to
be easy to bring 4k games over and
that's the result we're getting our dev
kit and the engagement we have from the
development community's been incredibly
strong okay I do want to go back quickly
to the press conference I think
after the press conference maybe it was
just a slew of games that you announced
or showed off or said this is coming to
Xbox well there's an ID at Xbox game or
first party or third-party game I think
there was some confusion among the
public about the phrasing before some of
the games I know like we have since
figured out but if people didn't read it
like there was console launch exclusive
there was exclusive and then some just
didn't have them could you clarify what
those mean is specifically like it's
Tacoma it's a console launch exclusive
could you talk more about what that
phrasing means yeah so console antics
console launch exclusive means the first
console that game will launch on where
the Xbox Xbox one shared some of those
games I think pub G is a good example
it's already on speeding yeah right so
it's going to launch on Xbox first so
what is the phrase that you use not sure
and when you're showing all of the games
you know people talk about well how long
is the timeline between when it launches
on Xbox windows on share and then a
logical next question I don't know
honestly anything about when those games
will launch on another plant announced a
here's when these games were launched
another punch really after the developer
in terms of when they want to do the
work to to make that work happen so in
order for consistency when there's kind
of different variability in what things
are happening these are games that will
launch first on Xbox console launch
exclusive some of them are already out
on PC so that's why we chose the term
that we did sure if you have feedback on
it I'd appreciate it
okay no yeah it's just where things like
Metro pop up and wondering you know
where what does that fall in because you
know you think naturally said world
premiere if I murmured directly which
means it was the first time yes game
play and among shown in amongst all the
other games I like exclusive exclusive
exclusive there was a little bit of like
confusion about what was showing up
where when and that kind of stuff but
it's good feedback yeah if it said Xbox
one Windows 10 exclusive that means it's
only shown on those platforms if it said
world premiere that means this is a game
that has a gameplay hasn't been show
before okay
games like Metro games like Assassin's
they're going to be available on all the
platforms
okay that's if it said console launch
exclusive that means the first console
at launch launches on will be Xbox one
sure that make sense yeah I was going to
return to the idea of the Xbox one X and
the iterative model that you've spoken
about following call almost like a
mobile phones so release cadence and
that kind of thing so how do you see the
future of Xbox going beyond Xbox 1x now
a lot of people will be wondering like
this is a console that looks
future-proof but at the same time
they're looking at the the kind of talk
about you know the modern mobile phone
model where a new model is available
every year and what kind of cadence do
we have for Xbox one Hardware going
forward now it's just so is this going
to be the last kind of a member of the
Xbox one family or can we expect in a
year or maybe two to have another
version of this console yeah I don't
have any kind of fixed iteration I feel
like I have to do Hardware on which is
kind of different than some of the
mobile hardware companies I think people
know that that watch it the video game
business especially consoles not made on
selling consoles right that's not where
the the money in profit is made in the
business frankly in a weird way selling
as few consoles as possible selling as
many games as possible it's kind of a
stupid scenario but is more valuable
than than just selling consoles people
don't use them I want to look forward
and figure out where the important
inflection points are of functionality
in the game space that we could build a
console for 4k was one of those native
4k I want a console in an 8 a 4k space
it had been kind of a shorter amount of
time since our Xbox one launched and
kind of a normal console generation
compatibility is incredibly important to
me we launched original Xbox backward
compatibility on stage we've been doing
a lot of work on 360 because I'm a
believer that you should be able to play
the great games of the past I think
certain people might not understand why
people want to go play those games but I
think it's important as an artform for
us to understand well where did what is
a quake and why did like I know quakes
coming back and what a great thing right
people can see so many of so much of
what is in gaming today was built on
great games of the past
I want this compatibility to be
something that's that's core to what
we're about so when we said we're going
to go build a 4k console with Xbox 1x I
want it to be part of the family of Xbox
one so that you knew if you were an S
customer or a one customer you decided
to move to Xbox one X to get 4k your
games and accessories we're going to
move with you so then looking forward
well what is the the
great step in hardware technology and
and software technology that we need to
take advantage of next in console I
don't know you know what it is please
tell me I'm kidding I look at that smart
competition you know I think about
framerate like people is it 120 frames
per second you look at that TVs don't
support that so we've got to go work
with the TV manufacturers if that was a
place we've been doing that with HDR and
4k now for a few years and that
relationship is good it's probably not
8k we're probably further out from 8k is
it something around mixed reality and is
that going to be the mix where we really
see something this is all the kind of
investigation that we're doing I want
our next console to be about an
important enabler of something that's
that's interesting into the game
developers and gamers themselves not
just okay we've clicked the top the
clock has ticked to a certain rate and I
need to go ship another piece hardware
okay cool
I do want to ask you something kind of a
personal question you know you caught
them know not save those for later
no we you come in and it seems like I
want to put it harshly it seems like a
lot of times as head of Xbox up until
like now you've been almost like fixing
things rebuilding and kind of cleaning
up messes that might be a harsh word but
you know like messaging around the Xbox
one the original Xbox ones launch was a
little bit muddled and I think you've
gone record saying could have done a few
things better but the Xbox one X seems
to be like your baby like your first
thing can you talk about that kind of
dichotomy between those two parts of
coming into Xbox and it's worth adding
to that like the sort of not connect not
being involved with Xbox 1x and that
kind of stuff is almost drawing it feels
like drawing a line in the sand from
what came before whilst not completely
cutting it off but it feels a little a
little bit more you in this in this
iteration of the console I'm always
uncomfortable when it becomes about me
because there's thousands of people that
work on Xbox that are smarter than I am
and we're harder than I am honestly like
I walk out on stage the thing that's in
my head is I'm representing very
talented and passionate team and I want
to do I wanna make them proud and so
it's not about me right it's about a
team of passionate people that really
care about gaming and want to do a great
job for us
in a job a little over three years both
s and X were hardware that this
leadership team thought about we wanted
to take the form factor of Xbox one make
it a little bit smaller which we did
with s at HD are the 4k blu-ray and I
love how s is doing like it's an
incredible for me it's incredibly strong
platform and piece of hardware and X was
a power like I
I've been around Xbox since we shot ship
the original one
I do think Xbox should be about power
and I think we'd kind of lost that at
the launch of Xbox one and when I saw 4k
and I saw such an interest there on the
PC side I thought we had some unique
capability to do something was going to
be a year later than what the
competition chose to do but I wanted to
hit something that could really do 4k so
I knew I was gonna have to wait there
was a risk in that on waiting a year but
the the team is has been very kind of
committed to making Xbox great and I
love the way the fans reacted you know
we come out I feel that the first party
teams more work to do in first party to
be honest and but we're totally focused
on that on the Kinect thing specifically
the Kinect adapter that works on s works
on Xbox one x so you can plug it in but
I'm listening to what our customers want
same question when people have asked me
here about VR and what the answer is
there and I'm committed in that space I
see it happening on Windows honestly I
just I don't get a lot of demand from
our customers for me to invest a lot in
platform for mix reality on console both
on content or but I'm going to listen to
what our customers want and that's
that's what we're here for
I guess the other thing is we're
stirring up is like obviously Sony has a
very commanding presence in in the
current generation and people always
inclined to kind of pick you against
each other but a lot from your
perspective and since you started kind
of taking control of it it seems like
you're trying to build instead of aiming
for who sells the most consoles is
trying to build that Microsoft and Xbox
ecosystem and having you know PC you
breathe in feeding into that and yeah
Xbox one so can you speak of it about
how that kind of has progressed and how
its kind of coming together especially
with the introduction of these new
consoles and
you see it kind of going forward yeah
you know even something like Minecraft
which we ship everywhere right I ship it
on playstation ship it on the switch
doing well does well across all
platforms yeah I think about gamers
first I think about games first I wanna
as a games industry to continue to grow
like that's why I'm here there are a
billion gamers on the planet our
business is doing well on Xbox Sony Sean
Andy those guys have done a great job
with Playstation and I love what
Nintendo's done with the launch of the
switch five years ago when I was here it
was all like the death of console
everybody's going to play on their iPad
why don't you guys go home right that
was honestly like that was those are the
questions and now we're sitting with
Sony doing really well we're doing well
the switch has come out of the gate
incredibly strong I don't get those
questions anymore so that feels good I
see a vibrancy in games that are here
across all platforms or watch Sony
yesterday I mean I thought spider-man
looked great
you know they've got a strong collection
of games that they're showing that first
party is doing well we showed 42 games
Mario this morning like you know it's
it's a great time to be in this industry
and for people to try to make this
industry about fighting with each other
as opposed to growing the industry
itself
I just don't think is a long term view
on an activity I love which is playing
games I grew up playing games with my
dad I played games with my daughter's I
want to be playing games for the next 40
50 years as long as I'm around and I
think the infighting that I feel both on
the internet and I'm sure you guys see
it on your message boards yeah it
doesn't feel like an investment in what
does it mean for gaming to grow we don't
have to see another company fail in
order for us to succeed right just it's
not part of the math of running the
business
there you go edit from Phil Spencer stop
the soul no I'm sure that just lit up a
bunch of I do have a bigger overarching
question about based on the hardware
side you do have I'm worried that you
know like people like us who are in tune
with the video game like hardware
lexicon kind yeah people who have
traditionally sucked the PC and know
that you know you every once a while you
upgrade is there any concern moving
forward that people who are still used
to just like get a PlayStation 3 then
you get a for like six years later then
you get a five however many years later
if that's what comes to be has there
been any concern within Microsoft like
how do you market like these console
upgrades to people who might not
understand where
that is going who are still used to that
traditional cycle of the new consoles
yeah so just to really sit if somebody
bought an Xbox one at launch and they
want to keep that console forevermore
that is a great customer for us i I
don't have to go sell them an S I don't
have to go sell them an X for the
business if you keep your launch day
Xbox one console and continue to play
games and play with your friends and buy
games that's a great scenario for us so
I'm not in a space where I have to go
sell somebody another piece of hardware
I think about the new consoles we do as
a way to expand our business and expand
people playing on our platform but if
somebody wants to stay on that first
console this is why compatibility has
been so key to me because I don't want
somebody to feel in consoles kind of the
only place left that creates these
somewhat artificial step functions where
everything you bought from us is now no
longer valid you have to go buy rebuy
things that's why I love the OG xbox
back comp at 360 putting the 360 games
in bat and game pass so if people don't
want to go buy the 360 games would
rather subscribe for 10 bucks a month
and get access to those games I think
that's a strength in our business so in
terms of instructing people or informing
people I'm in the business if you want
to go out and get a new console I want
to have a great console for you and I've
got a family from the value great entry
level Xbox 1s does most of what a lot of
people are going to want to do if you're
a gamer that wants the premium high
fidelity experience I've got that in the
Xbox 1x if you want to stay with your
Xbox one and that's where you want to
play love you you're a great customer
for that is quite a bold and brave thing
to do though right it's putting and
creating this hardware investing in and
putting you out there and just going if
you feel like it pick one up it's kind
of like you don't see that happening a
lot of sides it's kind of I must be
scary to put that out there in some on
some level right yeah it's kind of been
the console business for a long time and
it over don't really talk about it this
way but the this is why and I know I
definitely get some feedback on this
when I think about the health of Xbox I
think about how many people are playing
games like that is I if you're playing
on a one or you're playing on an S or
you're playing on an X that's actually
not the thing that creates like the
great relationship between us and our
customers so consequently I focused on
how many monthly active players do we
have on Xbox Live that's the critical
thing for us and if those people are
playing on Windows that's great
at I love that we have our first party
games on Windows we even get a lot of
usage now on mobile devices we got
minecraft there we're connecting all the
minecraft worlds we showed that on stage
user-generated marketplace so people can
buy content and use it in different
places like it's it's really about how
many players you have how many games
they want to go play and they buy and
their friends and all the stuff that
they're doing and the hardware business
has always just been a way of bringing
people into the ecosystem is not the
business itself okay so one of the
biggest chairs that you got at the press
conference gee oh gee it looks so can
you briefly I don't know we got very
little time left can you briefly talk
about what people can expect the kind of
how you're going to be releasing games
for them the disk base element of it and
what improvements there yeah I'll do
this quick so we only showed crimson
Crimson's one of my favorites from the
original Xbox I thought it actually
looked really good it's one of the
things they put in on a 4k screen a
little worried about how some of the old
games would look discs work so if you
got your discs when the game has been
enabled you'll be able to put a disc in
so just like 360 it's not every game
it'll be a smaller number of games than
it is on 360 mainly for rights reasons
those like some of those companies we go
back and the companies that publish
those don't exist anymore and we do have
to get rights clear and sure and other
things but we'll talk more about what's
coming coming this year and I'm excited
about the list
awesome so are we so offensive thank you
so much for coming out yeah thanks for
having it's fine we appreciate it have a
good rest of the show thank you cool yes
so if you were watching you can go watch
this video later on if you want to come
back to it but we do have more demos
coming up throughout the day next we
have ubisoft's South Park the fractured
but whole and we make sure you do that
correctly the fractured but whole we'll
see you then